pacific
today the u.s house meets at 10 30 in
the morning hour and at noon in
legislative session
live coverage can be seen here on c-span
next comedian bob newhart at the
national press club
he presented a lighthearted look at
political campaigns past and present and
also talked about his career in
television
recorded monday the program includes a
question and answer session and runs one
hour
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is monroe carmen
i'm president of the national press club
and editor-at-large at bloomberg
business news
i'd like to welcome
uh club members and their guests in the
audience can you hear me all right no
is this on i hope so
anybody else having
trouble okay well it's not on
melissa
go ahead
now can you hear me
well good afternoon i'll do it this way
my name is monroe carmen i'm president
of the national press club and
editor-at-large at bloomberg business
news i'd like to welcome all the club
members and their guests in the audience
as well as those of you watching on
c-span there we are
[Applause]
watching on c-span or listening to this
program on national public radio or the
global internet computer network
uh before introducing our head table i
would like to remind our readers
our readers our listeners
of
i'm a print journalist what can i tell
you
of upcoming speakers on monday
uh june 5th former president gerald ford
will present the annual gerald r ford
prize for distinguished reporting on the
presidency
on wednesday june 7th hungarian prime
minister beulah horn will present a
speech entitled from breaching the wall
to reaching the goal
and on thursday june 8 film critics gene
siskel and roger ebert will address
a press club audience and i guess
they'll talk about the movies
uh transcripts and audio and video tapes
of press club luncheons are available by
calling 1 800 npc2334
that's a a new number now 1 800
npc2334 that's the way to do it late
night television you know
if you have any questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your table pass them up to
me and i will ask as many as time
permits
i'd now like to introduce our head table
guests and ask them to stand briefly
when their names are mentioned
from your right ellen ferguson gannett
new service including
the burlington vermont free press
tom webb
tom webb of the wichita eagle
jessie merrill president meryl news and
feature syndicate
[Applause]
steve tatro washington bureau chief don
ray media group
mark russell
what does he do for a living
[Applause]
media general news service
immediate past president of the national
press club and our resident comedian
lin lin sweet washington bureau chief
chicago sun times
mark johnson media general news service
and ed and
the chairman of our speakers committee
uh christy wise the freelance journalist
who uh arranged today's luncheon
charles thompson producer cbs news 60
minutes
jack reynolds jack reynolds
communications welcome back jack
jeff hertrick senior producer
newschannel 8.
and bob garfield editor-at-large
advertising age
i'd like to thank melissa bender chad
taylor melanie abdo durmat and howard
ruth rothman for organizing today's
luncheon
our speaker today
and this is true began his professional
life
as an accountant
bob
[Laughter]
we'd like to invite you back to
speak to the press club
on what
the budget
gosh but i haven't practiced accounting
for years
no no we want you to talk about the
federal budget
oh you mean comedy
sure i'll be there
how did you go from accounting to comedy
well
tell you truth i really wasn't very good
at accounting
i couldn't understand how increasing
spending from two billion dollars to
four billion dollars amounted to a cut
i can see why you left the county
did you go directly into comedy no no
well this is hard to do i didn't really
[Laughter]
no i became an advertising salesman i
wasn't good at that either
what happened
i didn't have any clients
but i didn't want the boss to know so
i talked to myself on the telephone
sounds boring
it was
i mean talking to me i mean so i started
telling myself jokes
now you're getting somewhere
then i told jokes to other people that
got me into nightclubs theaters and
records
and weren't you on television once
in 1970
the bob newhart show
and the movies
yeah i starred in a picture called
hell is for heroes
who was in that
newt gingrich
[Laughter]
sounds like a democratic movie
i'm bipartisan i did a republican movie
too
what was that called
on a clear day i can see
forever
who is in that
senator strom thurman
with those credits i can see why you
left the movies
well i went back into television as a
new york do-it-yourself author
turned vermont
innkeeper
what happened to that
it's off the air
so you've got nothing to do
that's why i thought maybe i'd come down
and talk to the press club
when was the last time you were here
1961.
we told you we wanted you back
[Laughter]
okay bob you're on
[Applause]
thank you
thank you bud thank you that's um
you stay out of my field i'll stay out
of yours all right
you did that too good you really did
no i did i couldn't remember it and it
was 1961 i was here at the press club
and
obviously made such an impression on
people they said wow we got to get this
guy back as soon as possible
so
35 years later here i am um
i was handed a note
just before
we started
a start without me and signed
connie
[Laughter]
actually when i um
when i i got the letter from gil
actually asking me to be here i was very
honored i was reminded of a story about
the
yasha heifetz who um you know the
violinist and he took a date in like in
like february to appear at a grange hall
in
in north dakota in in november
and the day approached and and it was
snowing in new york and he couldn't get
out and it was snowing in the midwest
and he called up the the booker and he
said i'm sorry i can't uh i can't make
it and they said oh yeah she said you
know there are
three thousand people here in the grange
hall if you could possibly get out you
know they'd be they'd be terribly
disappointed he said well i'll try so he
finally got the last plane out of
laguardia got to denver and he had to
switch planes he finally got to
fargo and
it was about 11 o'clock at night he
walks in the grange hall
and there are 12 people there and
yasha went to the book he said you know
i've never appeared in front of such a
small
audience he said well you know there
were three thousand people here but they
were afraid you weren't coming and yasha
said well i really don't know if i can
do it
and and the booker said well
you know yoshi if you could just just
sing one two songs is all
so
i'm i'm highly honored i'm not sure you
have the right person but i'm i'm i'm
highly honored
i was i didn't saw in the paper today
that jonathan price you know the guy who
does the infinity uh commercials
apparently that came as a surprise to
the
to the to the japanese manufacturers uh
because their their new campaign
is now uh
when was the last time yes you saw this
kind of luxury in a 250 000 car
ah
also i i did a joke at such a small town
i did a joke on ron brown and the
problems he was having with the the
ethics committee uh and apparently he
heard about it but he was very nice
about it they called up and said
uh you know if if you have made
arrangements we'd like to make
arrangements for accommodations while
the two days you're here in washington
which i thought where's bell belhaven
is that near here
uh
i'm sure mark has is has talked about um
i'm intrigued by the the secretary
general uh butros brutos gali um
i'm intrigued from the standpoint of
the naming process that
that the parents went through when they
found
when they found out that that mrs
galley was expecting you know
you know what it uh well honey you know
we really ought to think of a first name
you know before the baby's here well
i've always liked boutros neutral
shadows
that's a nice name oh but yeah butchos
yeah butcher scally i like that and uh
we really ought to settle on a middle
name um
i always like bootros
but
bud was correct i was i started out as
an accountant and uh and really probably
could do some good here in in dc
with the budget because i i have i've
always had a theory if you got within
two or three bucks of it that was close
enough but
but i i really was an accountant
because why would you lie about that you
know if you
if you hadn't been an accountant why
would you ever tell someone you had been
an accountant
and there is by the way even though you
know take the boy out of accounting you
can't take accounting out of the boy and
there is an inequity
in the in the in the tax laws and it
favors large corporations and doesn't
favor individuals and they they have a
thing called a
tax loss carry forward and if a
corporation lose a lot of money in one
year they're able to spread that out
over
five years and there was a
large steel company i won't mention the
name a couple years ago they lost
838 million dollars in in one in one
year
and it always seemed to me like it comes
as a surprise to them like they they
they thought they were making money all
year you know
how do we do this yet tom
838 loss
you're out of here you added that wrong
tom let me
838 no thomas you're right yeah we sure
do now
now if you're a an individual you cannot
go to the irs and say um
you know my wife and i together we make
about um 65 000 a year uh
so far this year we've gone through a
million seven
[Laughter]
we were doing good through about all
march i guess
so i think i uh i also
i find in
american humor today a lot of people
we're becoming so super sensitive i mean
it's almost impossible not to offend
anyone we're becoming thin-skinned i
think that's that's kind of that's
either diversity is kind of what made
the country great and we could always
make they they tell a story all right
they tell a story in in california that
how can you tell if you're robbed by an
asian gang and they say well
your dog is gone but uh your kids math
homework is done so
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't you know i mean i i don't think
that's harmful that that's just
asian people uh they they
dog is a delicacy and uh and and and
they're damn good at math i mean
we're starting to i worked i once worked
this is true story i once worked for the
illinois state unemployment compensation
board it's not called that anymore it's
now called the department of human
resources
and you're no longer unemployed
you are an underutilized human resource
but i worked there and i worked behind
the counter and we got at this time we
got sixty dollars a week
and the claimants uh got fifty-five it's
true
it's true
and and they only had to come in one day
a week
[Applause]
now it
took me about a week to figure that out
because i'm
not the swiftest guy in the world but
anyway i got managed to get fired and
wound up on the other side of the
counter
i should explain a biographic
autobiographically i am a
three-quarters irish one-quarter german
the the humor i think comes from the
irish side um
because
the
germans have never been known as one of
one of the great fun races of all time
germans germans are very um
um
they're very literal you know they're
american humor is very often
perverse and we will very often say the
exact opposite of what we mean and
that's totally lost on germans like a
german tourist would come up to you and
say uh i don't mean to bother you but
your friend um
your friend curly over there has no hair
at all on his head
and tiny is over 350 pounds
but to sort of to kind of prove um
the more things change the more they
remain the same i would like to do a
routine i did
i'll say a
a number of years ago and that may even
be more true today than it than it was
at that time and it had it had to do
with the spin doctoring and the
packaging of the presidency and the
merchandising of the presidency and uh
it was based on a book by vance packard
called the uh the hidden persuaders
and
the premise of it was that if
we hadn't had this great president
president lincoln at the time of the
civil war if this science was well
advanced
then as it is today
the pr guys would have created a lincoln
out of the guy who was in office so
i imagine a phone conversation between
abe and his press agent
when ape calls from uh from gettysburg
yeah hi hi sweetheart how's everything
going kid
yeah i got you know what seems to be the
problem babe
you you're thinking about shaving it off
i see that's part of the image abe yeah
uh you know we're getting we're getting
a lot of uh sound bites on that yeah
that in the uh and the shawl
you do you don't have the shawl
where where's the charlie
it's in washington what are you wearing
abe
it's a kind of cardigan abe
yeah abe i leave the beard on and find
uh find a shawl okay yeah all right
what's the problem
your gag riders yeah they're here what
what's the problem
you're getting a lot of complaints about
grant and his drinking
uh
i don't see the problem maybe but you
know you knew he was a lush when you you
appointed him yeah
well i'll see what i can do i'll get him
working on it uh abe you got the speech
right you haven't changed the speech
why do you change the speeches all the
time
you you typed it
dave how many times we have to tell you
on the backs of envelopes
it looks like you wrote it on that on
the train coming down you know
but could you memorize it and then write
it on the backs of the envelopes
any other changes there
you
you changed four score and seven
two to eighty 87.
yeah i know it's the same thing eh but
uh
you know we we test marketed that in
erie and they loved it
any anything else
people will little note hey what could
possibly be wrong with that
nor long remember abe they'll remember
it
hey what are you going to say it's a
great speech i think everybody's going
to remember it
you come off a braggart abe yeah
do the speech the way charlie wrote the
inaugural all right all right
all right
anything else you talked to newsmen abe
we've asked you not to talk to newsmen
well you always put your foot
now see that's what i mean a no you you
were a rail splitter then an attorney
well it doesn't make any sense maybe you
wouldn't give up your law practice to
become a rails player
hey read the biography we'll you'll save
a lot of trouble on this end
hey you got a piece of paper there now
take this down
you can fool all of the people some of
the time
and some of the people all of the time
but you can't fool all the people uh
well you keep doing it differently
that's why abe
the la the last quote we got was you can
fool all the people all the time abe
uh abe hold on the gag writers come up
with something
oh that's funny
yeah they come up a great line i grant
the next time the reporters bug you
about grant
yeah tell him
are you going to find out what brand he
drinks
and send a case of it to all your other
generals
[Laughter]
no no no it's like it's like the brand
it's like the bran the brand is the
reason he's winning abe
no no no abe uh
abe you use it it's funny trust me
that'd be this saturday uh yeah i'm
sorry i can't make it um
yeah just you and uh what's her name
mary mary right at the white house um
you try seward
he's out of town on the alaskan deal uh
oh that's a shame but then you and you
and mary be alone at the um
yeah
why don't you take in a play
thank you bob
uh now comes the hard part the
questions from the
from the audience
uh this one has to do with presidential
humor
how do you rate the president clinton's
sense of humor
compared with other presidents you have
known
um
wow um
if we ever see it um
no i i don't know i don't i don't i
think presidents aren't supposed to i
guess the last funny president was was
really uh
jfk i mean he had a sense of humor about
himself and and it's kind of been
missing ever since
ever since that time uh
i i think humor is wonderful i think
it's a necessary part of
of life in america and it helps us get
through some really really tough times
and
i'd like to see more humor
aside from the budget in
in government
what do you think about newt gingrich is
he easy to make fun of
and will you
i leave that kind of up to mark i'm not
much of a
political political animal um
uh i
knew this uh
as we
as i was coming over here there was he
had some kind of breakfast at the hotel
we're staying at and
i guess he does a lot of breakfast that
kind of thing um
i i am um
i guess politically i'm an agnostic um
you know i i know it exists i just don't
think you can prove it that that's uh
who's uh
brainchild were the brothers daryl and
what are they doing now
they're running for the senate like a
lot of other people
that no that was uh
the writers came up with that i would i
would take credit for it if i come up
with it but the writers came up with it
and they were they were wonderful they
were a wonderful um
anomaly and very hard to explain um but
two people would you know wind up with
the same name but uh
whenever uh they would they were in a
scene we always had to put a aside about
two minutes because they got applause
every time they walked in and you just
kind of freeze wherever you were and
then the applause died down you go on
with the scene and they were a wonderful
addition to
to newhart and i think
had a lot to do with the success of
newhart
who was your favorite tv wife suzanne
plichette or mary fran
this is from mrs newhart
[Laughter]
well susie and i were um i i told mary
fran when we started uh newhart after
the bobby art show that she had a very
tough job because susie
we had a very special kind of chemistry
and that kind of thing you just can't
create and and i told her she had one of
the toughest jobs in
in television and she did and i thought
she did a an admirable job of it but
that
the relationship between
susie and myself was something was
something very special and i still i see
it on the show today and it's it's uh it
was a wonderful time um i remember
saturday night we talked to mark about
it we were uh
saturday night at one point was all in
the family mash
i married tyler moore us and the carol
burnett show and uh
it was it was kind of a golden age and
but we were so busy doing it we didn't
have um
we didn't really have a chance to enjoy
it but um
looking back now it was it was a lot of
fun and i'm very proud of both shows i
think they were very well written and uh
very well acted
no not me
[Applause]
well what do you think of the comedy
shows on television today
and corollary
with the number of comedy clubs
diminishing what's the future of the
business this is from a fellow who's a
stand-up comedian and he's sitting down
in the audience
uh
mark i wish you'd have asked me this
[Laughter]
and we were up in the room you had all
kinds of time all year
it is i i have a uh
i enjoy anybody who makes people laugh i
i don't i don't draw the line that say
that's over the line that's that's uh
grotesque the good ones are going to
are going to stay and the bad ones are
going to fall by the wayside but even
the bad ones
will have undergone the experience of of
standing up in front of an audience and
they will have prepared them for later
things i i love
i love comedy i love people who do
comedy and and i don't find any
difference today uh between what i did
and what they're doing um
the the boundaries may be expanded but i
think that's that's what's supposed to
happen in comedy
[Music]
my head is off to anyone who makes
anybody laugh in any form
in these uh days of uh political
correctness could you still make fun of
mrs webb the bed driver and other
sensitive subjects and caricatures
that's what i was talking about earlier
about everybody being very sensitive
about
uh
i actually get a reaction now when i do
mrs webb is the lady in the driving
instructor uh and
and because it's a woman i there's kind
of a rumble
that goes through the audience
like that and uh
so i explained to them i said it was
never my intention to to make this a
sexist routine it was written over 35
years ago and performed 35 years ago
uh and and that it uh i think of mrs
webb is one of my dearest friends and um
for those
women in the audience who are sensitive
to that that it doesn't have to be
a
a woman driver i i will make it a a
chinese driver and
and then proceed to go
all she knows
and then tell them you can have eight
more minutes of this or you can have it
as a woman driver so
they're usually out for the i mean that
that's part of what the the sense of
humor about we're so we're losing and i
i think it's just
i mean i wrote it i know what what was
on my brain when i wrote it and i know
my brain wasn't telling me make fun of
women i just found it a very fertile
funny area and
i i really am concerned i think we get
uptight about so many things and just
you know
loosen up you know
well now that we've had that
horrendous baseball strike of uh last
year
could you still do abner doubleday again
oh boy that's um and will you do it yeah
they they you probably know it better
than i do and
it throws me off to watch your lips move
along with mine as i'm doing it
i'll try but i'm not sure it it uh i
haven't done it for a long time
it was a thing on inventions and
how you today you take it to a marketing
company and they market
that you know they look at it from all
different angles and and decide whether
it's going to be successful or not and i
imagined if we'd ever have baseball if
uh
if avenue doubleday had gone to one of
these
merchandising companies and with his
idea for baseball and i may miss parts
of it because i haven't done it for a
while but uh i imagine a phone
conversation that went went something
like this
uh olympic games
what what can i do for you mr double a
you got a game huh how many couples mr
doubleday
18 people
that's a hell of a lot of people mr
doubleday
well the the ideal game is um
you know you get uh two three couples
over the house to get a little swacked
and uh
sure sure tell me about it huh
you you got a pitcher
and a catcher
and they
and they throw this ball back and forth
and that's that's it is it mr doubleday
okay
a guy from the
guy from the other side
stands between him with a bat
and he he swings at it does he mr double
a
he
he may or he may not swing at it
why why why wouldn't he swing at it mr
doubleday
if it if it looked like it was gonna be
a ball
yeah would you mind explaining that mr
doubleday
as as long as it's above the knees
and below the shoulders
that's that's a strike
three strikes and you're out
and then and then three balls
four balls
why why four balls mr double day
no no one's ever asked you before
[Laughter]
or he may hit it what happens if he hits
it he runs as far as it can go he can go
as long as it
as long as it stays what
as long as it stays fair
what's what's fair mr doubleday
you you have these two white lines mr
doubleday
no i don't want to hear about the
infield fly rule mr doubleday
that's the most complicated game i've
ever heard of my life thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
of all the routines you've done
which skit earned you the most to claim
and likewise the most censure
um
the the one i'm most proud of is the abe
lincoln thing because i think it said
the most i think was the best piece of
writing i ever did um
uh
commercially the driving instructor was
probably successful um i got some flack
for the retirement party where guys
retiring from
from a company and he's he's bombed out
of his mind because that's that's the
only way he could work for this company
um
that's the only way you could get
through it and i always
i always thought it made a kind of
comment but somebody misunderstood and
they said how can you make fun of this
of this charlie bedlow and i said i'm
not making fun of charlie betlow i'm
i'm making fun of the company that made
charlie bettelow the way he is and uh
i would say that in the submarine
commander they're all kind of it's like
asking what which child is your favorite
child i um i i've enjoyed doing all of
them uh over the years and uh
the most fun is is the next one whatever
that one's gonna be
well
several people have asked for a little
bit of the uh bus driver training skit
so you can get the little old lady
spinning down the aisle and
and a few others
well of course that's the punch line bud
but
[Laughter]
that one that one i don't remember i
have that is too old i really don't
remember them
no you know what do it what
[Music]
little old lady spinning down the aisle
that's it that's it that's the punchline
well uh it must be timing because i get
a laugh on that
uh
why are there no
why are there no variety shows anymore
like the old ed sullivan show
well you're asking me questions i i
really don't i don't know why there
aren't um
the you've got mtv and and you can see
everybody for almost nothing um you can
see him on the tonight show i guess
that's why when i came out
it was
i mean doing the sullivan show
was um
i mean that was the epitome that was
that was the very height and it was
abjectly i remember one time i was
i'm standing backstage and you never
knew who you were going to follow and i
followed
of all things the french samurai act
it was a french samurai and uh they come
out and they did this whole thing and
now ed calls them over now i know in the
booth they're going crazy saying oh my
god why they don't talk
dick why the hell is that caught so ed
ed calls him
say where
where are you fellows from
that's true
and the two frenchmen look at each other
like suddenly they learned english
now ed does what all americans do when
people don't understand
what we're saying in a foreign tongue he
yells at them
where
are you fellows
from
so finally one of them realized what ed
is saying and he says
perez
that said
well you go back to paris you say hi to
our
our very good friend general de gaulle
now the chances of a french samurai act
ever running into general de gaulle
and that's what i miss about television
today i guess
our television comedy shows now too
dependent on one central character
instead of an ensemble cast
you know jack benny had a whole group of
characters now we've got
well jack
um i i think they still i think seinfeld
is very much a
ensemble cast and um
fraser and and matt about you and the
good shows all the good shows
um
i remember jack manny a story jack benny
uh they told about jack money that he
was he had ronald coleman on and uh
there were it was just the script
reading and
jack said uh who was one of the dearest
man in the world said
he said that's that's a funny line give
that give that to dennis because that's
better coming from dennis so i gave it
andy thanks to that no don't take that
line away from me give it to phil phil's
much better and wound up giving all his
the great lines away and the ronald
coleman at the end when the script
reading was over he said jack
you gave away all your your best lines
and jack said
yeah but i'll be back next week
uh we understand you play a lot of golf
with uh john rickle
what's his handicap
his mouth is his handicap
no don and i are good friends uh we we
just returned from uh it actually
started out in a very strange way um i
was approached and they said um
don doesn't have any doesn't have a
friend would you mind being his
friend and i thought it was a temporary
job i had no idea
it would last 30 years we just came back
from southeast asia had we just had a
great time together and it's that
inexplicable thing our wives
have great fun together and and we enjoy
each other's company i guess we're
opposites but we are genuinely good
friends
what do you think of connie chung's
current situation and what would you
advise her to do
um
i i wouldn't advise cbs to do anything
there i mean they're doing such a great
job right now i i can't
far be it for me to advise them
do you do you still keep in touch with
johnny carson and what's he up to now
uh i still keep in touch with john uh
john is he's he was he's he
is the best he's by he's the standard by
which all other talk shows will ever be
uh judged and he is and i i that's not
to put down a letterman or leno or any
others but
after
30 years let's
you know let's judge uh how good they
were um i mean what he did was
absolutely incredible it was i find it
incredible i couldn't have done i did it
for three weeks
and i was a blithering idiot at the end
of three i mean the man
dedicated his life to that show and
and did one thing that similar to the
jack benny thing he made he made you
look good you knew when you were on the
when you were sitting there you knew
johnny wasn't going to leave you out
there you knew he was
he he was going to he was going to help
you out and never make you look bad
because
he knew he was going to be there
tomorrow you know it's um
i miss it a lot um i miss him a lot and
i think maybe now people are beginning
to realize how really good he was at
what he did
what about the comedians of the old days
would
would fred allen for example
make it today
oh yeah yeah i think so i i think the
comedians will make it today are the
comedians who had respect for the
comedians that preceded them uh
i mean i know i did i found jack benny
and fred allen um
enormous towns if there's anyone you
could if any any when you could study as
a comedian coming up i would i would
think would be jack benny
um
uh i also i was influenced by bob and
ray i was influenced by um um benchley
and thurber and max shulman and uh
um
i i think
i i have a feeling that that if you're
that if you're able to do stand-up
comedy i i think
i really think you have to keep doing it
i think it's um
i mean there are some performers who've
stopped doing it and i don't think they
should i think it's a unique thing to be
able to do
and if you're able to do it well i think
you have an obligation
to do it i think if you're able to make
people laugh it's one of the best things
you can ever do in your life there's
certainly more important things but
it's one of the best things you can ever
do in your life and i don't think you
should ever you should ever stop doing
it
[Applause]
where uh did the concept of the
telephone routine really come from it
wasn't for me
[Laughter]
that well the telephone routine was uh
i'm giving credit for it but i i
certainly didn't originate it uh shelly
berman before me uh did telephone
routines and
mike and lane did a lot of telephone
routines uh
george jessel used to do uh
telephone retains one of the earliest
records ever made was a thing called
cohen on the telephone
so it's been around for a long time the
the interesting thing about the
telephone routine and about the um
especially abe lincoln is nothing that
i'm saying is funny it it's what is
funny is what is unheard
uh what you hear abe saying on the other
end of the
of the conversation and it's it's kind
of a collaborative thing between
um
the audience and the performer and and
um
people kind of pat themselves on the
back because we're kind of in tune at
that point they know what i'm saying and
i know what they're saying um
but i i can't take credit for
originating it was around long before i
started doing it
this is meant to be a friendly question
what's it like to be anywhere in the
country
sitting in a motel room
flipping on the television set
and seeing yourself from 20 30 40 years
ago
it is uh
it's very nice is what it is
i mean aside monetarily from from the
rewards uh uh just
to know that you spent a life that that
you made people laugh and and uh and
they're laughing and um
that's that's um
well i i wouldn't trade places with
anybody to be honest with you
[Music]
the questioner
has trouble with all the trash
television that's filling the tube today
do you see that coming to an end or
getting worse
um
i don't i don't watch it so i i don't
i i'm i'm certainly i'm not the person
to answer that i the height i ever saw
with in la
the height of trash television um
it was a um
they came out at news break at 10
o'clock and they said the
headless nude body found by railroad
tracks
film at 11.
i defy anyone to go to sleep knowing
that that's coming up at 11 o'clock
uh you mentioned benchley where are the
benchleys the thurbers the ring lardners
the sj perlmans of today have you found
any out there
oh uh russell um um
i i think dave berry i think they're out
there um
they're gonna be some names i forgot
they're very um
the the paraplegic i forget his name
anyone help me out with that he's
terribly funny terribly sick but
terribly
terribly funny i think they're out there
they're out there on a different uh i
meant russell baker of course
no no no
[Laughter]
no mark is is up there
all by himself we all know that
especially mark knows that
well over the years who makes you laugh
the most
uh that's a that's a tough question
because um i um
i have so many friends that are
comedians and and so many comedians make
me laugh um um
don rickles obviously uh shecky green
buddy hackett um
there's so so many uh i find seinfeld
very funny i find channeling very funny
letterman leno
um
a young kid named
um
um
jake johansen i think he is very
inventive
this is going to sound strange to you
the person that makes me laugh the most
is richard parker he is
uh we certainly work in two different
arenas
but he is about as funny as human being
as god has ever put on the face of the
earth and i'm indebted to him
uh he does a thing called mud bone i
don't know if you're familiar with it
but mud bone is it's it it's beyond
comedy it's it's um
it's mark twain and uh
will rogers it it he it's a look into
black american culture that that i would
never have seen and his insights are his
insights are just um incredible i'm
sorry that richard is you know as you
all know is not doing well health-wise
but um
whenever i got
down and comedians get down god knows we
get down and
i would always put on a richard pryor
album and listen to it and
pick me up like that and
i guess that's what we're supposed to do
that's what we do
well now that you've uh returned to the
national press club do you expect to be
returning to television anytime soon
uh well let's see uh having been an
accountant this shouldn't be that hard
uh
uh 95 and 35 would be 20 30. so i'm due
back here in 2030.
and
i
i don't see television as as something
um i'm not actively pursuing that uh it
it's um
it's another time i uh
that certainly has not said with
bitterness or anything it's just a
different a different time and
i certainly enjoyed the time i had i
mean i i couldn't ask for
more fun um
i don't see television as really being
i don't see myself on television in the
future
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
can you tell us a little bit about how
you came up
with the final episode for new heart the
the flashback to the bob newhart show
well it yes very easy uh it was my
wife's idea um i i was having oddly
enough having trouble with cbs uh in the
uh
the uh
in the sixth year of the new art show
they kept the
the the in show and they kept moving it
around 10 30 at night and i finally said
oh the honey i told my wife stood the
hell with it i said this is my last year
i don't want to do any more because i'm
not going to let the show limp off i you
know
um and and so she's we happened to be at
a
christmas party in beverly hills and um
susie was there and she said well you
know if my wife said you know if this is
the final season
um
you should do a dream sequence and you
should wake up in bed with susie and and
the whole
at that point six years of new heart had
been would have been a dream and
i said oh my god that's a great idea it
turned out i did two more years of new
heart and then then when the final we
realized it was the final show
um
i gave the writers the idea and they
fleshed it out and did a very good job
of the japanese buying
all around the end
but but the idea of waking up in bed and
susie being there was my wife's idea and
it's
entertainment weekly it was the number
it's the number one
uh final episode um in their estimation
[Applause]
uh why do you feel your last show bob
didn't do better
oh yeah
you know it's all the idea of getting
off one question too late you know
[Laughter]
everything was going so damn well and
then
i'm that's one of the reasons i don't
see myself on television because i don't
know what was wrong with it it was it
had all the elements that i thought um
were there for a successful show we had
great writers we had the writers from
cheers god knows it doesn't get any
better than that
we had a great cast
you kind of become your own worst enemy
because people start saying i don't know
i like the bob newhart show better i
like new heart better well i like this
better um
i'm at a loss to explain why it didn't
work because it had those elements
it it obviously didn't and
it was quite painful experience for a
year and a half but
there is a life after sitcoms
well your shows
played before live audiences that's a
hallmark of your career was that by your
choice and what did you like about it
yeah that was by by choice we all were
doing at that time we were all doing
shows mary tyler moore all in family uh
lucy who started the whole thing that
was always done in front of a live
audience i i always insisted on a live
audience
uh because um
you you just my background was
nightclubs and and you just you you
don't want to be totally on top of the
material you want to have that kind of
unknown the unexpected kind of happening
i found i always performed better i
found the other actors always performed
better i found the writing was always
better
in front of a live audience
two things i did insist on i when the
bob newhart show started i um
i insisted i'm playing a psychologist
not a psychiatrist because they're
psychiatrists in my estimation dealt
with
much more serious i didn't want to make
fun of schizophrenics or manic
depressives um
and
the other thing was i didn't want to do
a
show about how stupid daddy was and and
how the kids all would pitch in and look
at the fix that he's got himself into
and how do we get him out of it and
we love daddy and thank god we got him
on it i didn't want to do that kind of
show the dumb father show
so i said
i
i don't want to have children i mean
there are enough shows on the air with
children i don't want to have children
i think it should be a show about two
adults
and uh in the sixth year i got a script
and and i read it um we're gonna do it
monday and i read it sunday night and um
emily was pregnant and uh
i called up uh i called up the producer
mike zenberg and i said mike um i said
funny script he said well really he said
we were we were afraid you you weren't
uh you weren't happy i said no it's a
very funny script
did you like the part about emily being
pregnant oh god that's funny it's a very
funny scene um
who are you going to get to play bob
[Laughter]
i mean that's the kind of show i that's
exactly the kind of show i didn't want
to do there are enough
i'm not putting them down there enough
good ones of those it's just i didn't
want to do that i didn't want to do that
kind of show
thank you before we get to our famous
last question i have a couple of gifts
for you
this is a certificate of appreciation
for
being with us well that's very nice
thank you
you probably got one of those
it's a bit yellow but i have it yeah
and uh this is the national
press club the last one you got i think
was about four ounces this is we've
enlarged them since
the last yeah thank you very much it
really it really has been a a pleasure
and and will always be um it was then a
great moment in my life and it is this
day a great moment in life to be asked
to be here and
i appreciate it thank you very much
[Applause]
and now we're getting to the final
question
you may or
may not be aware
that there is a drinking game
called
bob
in which viewers of your shows
take a swig
every time
a character says bob
did you authorize this game and were you
and well you were enlisted by the
liquor industry
i'm i'm aware of the game um
i've received um
i received one emmy uh a peabody um
i was inducted into the television hall
of fame and uh
the last thing i want to be known for is
causing more hangovers in college dorms
and than any man a lot it's a tribute to
the show uh
i i worry a little bit about it because
i i certainly wouldn't want anyone
playing high bob and then driving or
going somewhere but uh
it's a tribute to to the show the show
finally came into its own uh we were
always behind mary and
and mary's show was an incredibly
wonderful show and
marvelously cast uh
but finally the bob newhart show came
into its own and and
even high bob is kind of a strange
recognition of it
but i guess the college students
wouldn't be watching if they didn't
think it was funny
that's what i'm proud most proud of i
think that the bob knew how joe finally
would which is not the bob newhart show
it was obviously all the writers and all
the and the cast um
uh
i i'm i'm most proud of that that it
finally is being recognized as being a
a pretty good
a pretty good show
well i think i can speak for everyone
here when we say it was a very good show
thank you very much for being with us
this afternoon sarah and we thank you
all in the audience and uh i guarantee
you it will not be another 35 years
before you come back
good afternoon
thank you sir thank you thank you yeah
we're a little shelf absorbed
[Music]
all right
this program will re-air saturday
evening at 6 p.m eastern time on c-span
today at the national press club ford
motor company chairman alex trotman
and in june speakers include former
president gerald ford movie critics gene
siskel and roger ebert and actress
sharon stone
today the u.s